meanwhile in studio we have a special
guest well actually five special gas we
have our cousin rang and she is the
co-owner of the cup which is a cupcake
boutique in the central west end yeah we
are right around the corner just a block
or two from here Oh Ivan that red velvet
yeah that's right I heard you like the
red velvet but y'all would have danced
but those about this special cupcake
which is just for the same field cup
isn't that right it is we developed this
cupcake and design this cupcake
specifically for this couple of weeks
and we are really excited about it
because we've partnered with the st.
Louis chess club and this is the first
time we've had a partnership together
and we both feel like it has gone really
well this is actually one of our most
popular pairings of flavors are dark
chocolate cake which is like devil's
food and then our vanilla buttercream
frosting and we dressed it up and made
it look a little more professional for
for this two weeks for the sink build
Cup I like the par I we thought that
that would have universal appeal and
actually it has people who are not even
in the area for the sink filled Cup are
being drawn to this cupcake and choosing
it I mean I actually have one of my
Instagram feed actually because I have
this horrible this horrible horrible
thing but I actually made a bet with
another poker player I also play poker
in addition to chess that I wouldn't eat
bread or cake for like four weeks so i
can actually only have the icing in the
little pot so when does that end a few
weeks or i could be a hundred dollars
every infraction is 100 hours it might
be worth it you might be I know you guys
on air let me know should I have a
hundred and one hundred and five dollar
cupcake 103 maybe you could freeze it
for a few weeks now I'm going to come
back now I'm gonna sound like a total
degenerate but I actually I actually
lost another cupcake once this come take
that was it was somebody's birthday and
I bet that he was going to prefer there
was these wonderful cupcakes and I was
going to bet that he would prefer if I
bought him with an l 0 on so I bought
both and
I mean of course I was wrong so tell us
chocolate or vanilla personally
chocolate she knew she would have won
the bag we chose it for this because
they're lots of chocolate lovers out
there yeah I'm a huge fish I mean it
tests the thing is why usually people at
the especially at the high level they
prefer to start with the white pieces so
if you had a vanilla cupcake chess game
bursac ilat cupcake chess game which i
think is a good idea by the way right
it's a great idea actually yeah it's not
a good idea you got to eat the
opponent's pieces when you guys exactly
wow that could cost a lot of calories
thank you very much for joining us and
for those of you who are thinking about
coming in the central west end just
another reason definitely check out the
cupcakes thank you thank you Grandmaster
endorsement over here thank you back to
Maurice Ashley chocolate or vanilla
Maurice chocolate of course come on
seriously